hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel uh we are back to another
systems design video after a brief
Hiatus last week to go talk with Stefan
uh I won't lie it is a slightly
disappointing feeling to uh spend like
eight hours a week making systems design
videos only to spend about 30 minutes a
week metaphorically just like pooping on
camera to make a video with Stefon and
then seeing it get four times the views
as uh my normal videos but that's okay
we push onwards um for those of you who
are very attracted by uh L7 titles in uh
videos from now on I should let it be
known that I am an L7 rzl and uh please
watch all of these systems designed
videos so without further Ado let's talk
about building some video games okay
let's start over because my pencil was
not working so if you weren't looking at
the title very much uh what we're going
to be building in this game is something
like fortnite cod war zone uh pubg uh
any of those types of games where
basically you've got a bunch of
different players in a big uh you know
2D playing field and then as the game
progresses uh we've got some sort of
Zone and it's gradually closing in on
you so the area that you're allowed to
be in as an alive player is gradually
decreasing you've got a bunch of people
that start out in this Lobby and the
number of players actively in the game
begins decreasing so for example let's
imagine me and Tech lead are in this
Zone as you can see I've absolutely
sniped him across the zone right there
good job
Jordan so even though this is mainly for
one of these Battle Royale games it can
really apply to any video game where
there's going to be movement and uh you
know like a a massive 2D Zone where the
players can occupy any part of that it's
going to be less significant for
something like rocket league for example
where there's only six people in a game
and it's a pretty small playing field uh
but you know if we're talking about like
World of Warcraft or something where
they can potentially be a lot of
different players on a server or
Minecraft this could potentially be
useful there so let's go through some
formal problem requirements basically
like I mentioned we're building a battle
royale game we've got a bunch of players
who can move around they can interact
with a bunch of stateful items where the
stateful items are not necessarily
playable so for example in pubg you know
you can drive around in a car uh you can
drop things you can pick them up you can
open doors things like that cool
additionally in a given Lobby let's say
we can have up to 1,000 players so
ideally we can get a lot of load on our
server and this problem isn't too easy
for us additionally let's imagine there
are tens of thousands of additional
items right if this is pubg like
literally every single door can be
opened uh you know there are all of the
just like random chests and stuff that
can be looted there's actually a ton of
uh basically items that you have to keep
track of State for if it's fortnite uh
pretty much every building that you
build is adding state to the game server
because everyone has to know that that
thing was built cool and then also we
should be able to support pings of like
10 Millies uh so you know if you have a
ping of 10 it basically means every 10
milliseconds you're hearing from the
server and you're you're probably
sending stuff to the server as well so
that's a 100 times per second per user
so we really have to make this thing
fast uh we're probably going to want to
be storing everything in memory and uh
yeah we'll talk about that more in a
little
bit cool so the first thing that we're
going to do is talk about at a very high
level let's say I'm a game client right
I'm playing on my laptop over here and
I'm trying to communicate uh my game
State updates right because now I have
to basically tell everyone else who's
playing the video game what it is that
I'm doing so what's one way that I could
do that well for starters I could send
them the exact keystrokes that I'm
pressing right so that's easy because at
the end of the day it's just one letter
that I'm pressing at a time or maybe a
mouse click or something like that but
at the same time this is actually really
hard to implement the reason being well
we don't know exactly when I click them
right if I'm on the receiving end of all
of these keystrokes I might see you know
WD click but I don't know exactly when
those clicks were done and as a result
of that uh I can't really replicate that
state back on my own machine so in
theory I could include the time stamps
that I clicked everything but then that
still doesn't really makes sense because
as far as synchronization goes uh
between multiple computers everyone's
going to have slightly different time
stamps and it's just not going to work
out so let's go ahead and Nyx that
strategy this won't
work and what we'll do is we'll move on
to strategy number two which is ideally
going to be quite a bit better which is
actually going to be sending game State
messages right so basically you know for
example if I'm player two I can move to
100 comma 300 I can send this out to all
the other clients and the all all the
other clients can apply this on their
own machine now of course if they're
applying this too slowly this is going
to be a pretty bad experience but that's
why I said we have to make everything
pretty fast and so another thing to note
is that you know depending on the type
of message we may be able to drop some
of them so if I'm going like 100 300 and
then I'm going 101 300 and then 102
300 maybe if one of the other clients
drops this 101300 message it's not so
bad because they're going to get the 100
to and then all of a sudden I'm back to
the proper state that I should be
that being said you know if we're
talking about like shooting a bullet uh
if another client doesn't understand
that I've shot a bullet that's quite bad
because that bullet could have hit them
they might have died and then all of a
sudden now we're in an inconsistent
state so some messages do definitely
need to be delivered others are
droppable okay uh with that in mind
let's quickly touch upon peer-to-peer
gaming because this is something in
theory that's always going to come up
right if you can avoid having a
centralized server it may actually be
quite useful because then you don't
necessarily have one single bottleneck
where all of the updates have to go
through so I guess the question is you
know is it actually worth doing this and
I would say maybe maybe it is possible
but at the end of the day if you have a
thousand people in a game sending
messages to a thousand other clients
that's probably too much now it is
possible that say you know you've got a
few different game servers right that
all act as leaders and are all basically
sending messages between clients and
that's possible too but then what we
could happen is uh we could get right
conflicts right so if I write to one
leader someone else writes to another
leader and basically in my leader right
I'm saying I shoot you and in your
leader right you're saying you shoot me
well who actually wins that we could do
some sort of weird conflict resolution
but then all of a sudden on my screen
it's going to look like I won that
battle and then 5 seconds later I'm
going to get a message telling me hey
you're dead and I'm going to be like
well that sucked I have no clue it
happened so ideally you do probably want
some single leader to actually order all
of these rights cool and then another
question is okay well if a client did go
down how can we actually store the game
State somewhere so that we can restore
that state on the client because you
know if we're just sending messages from
one client to another I guess the only
way to actually restore State there
would be for the client that went down
to ask all of the other clients for
their game State and then basically
merge them together somehow which is not
ideal and then the final thing is uh
another thing that's always going to be
important with video games is stopping
people from cheating right so if I'm
just sending messages from my client to
your client and there's no validation
step in there I can basically say hey I
just moved across the entire map and you
might say oh okay that seems reasonable
now to be fair you could do the
validating on your individual client but
then we're doing a lot of duplicate work
it might be better to just centralize
that entire process cool so like I
mentioned you know if I'm moving from
100 300 to 300 300 that's just
teleporting that's not fair I can't be
moving around like that I mean in
reality I'm fast as but in the
video game we like to keep people honest
so what do we do well we can actually go
ahead and introduce a centralized game
server right so the point of the game
server is that it's basically storing a
snapshot of the entirety of the game
state so it gets all of these
incremental messages from all the
clients of their own game state so say I
want to say I'm moving to 200 comma 200
now all of a sudden the centralized game
server is saying okay Jordan is at 200
comma 200 and not only does it do that
but it also is going to be responsible
for delivering all of those messages to
the interested parties
okay so what are the pros of an approach
like this well for starters we now have
much fewer active connections for client
if I'm playing the video game I just
have to connect to the game server
that's it I don't have to connect to a
thousand other things which is great we
can also perform some validation against
cheating now in the diagram that I have
here if we're assuming that doing the
validation against cheating takes a
while maybe we're running some sort of
uh you know like kind of simple
regression model or something to realize
if a if an individual player is cheating
we can actually pipe all of those
updates into Kafka
and then handle them on our anti-che
server and then handle that Downstream
if the anti-che server says oh player
two is cheating we can kick him from the
game eventually but you know maybe
you'll have to take an extra 10 seconds
to determine
that another thing is that we can
restore game state to failed clients so
like I mentioned the entire point of the
game server is basically to cash the
existing version of the game State and
also send out all of the messages that
are incremental so if we have a cash
game State what it means is that a
client that goes down and com comes back
up can go to the game server and say hey
I need that game State back and the game
server can actually respond with it and
then also another important thing is
conflict resolution or message ordering
because we're writing to one node all of
our rights that go through properly are
going to be linearizable so if I shoot
you and you try and shoot me at the same
time only one of us is actually going to
be staying
alive cool let's talk about restoring
gam State because while I acted like
this was trivial in reality it probably
isn't the idea here is that you know if
I'm a client and I go down I want to be
able to get the entire game State back
on it because I'm going to have lost
that it was probably in memory and even
if I did write it to disk I'm going to
have missed some updates since then so I
probably want to go ahead and ask the
server for all of the updates since then
now in theory you could probably read
every single incremental update one at a
time but actually applying those would
probably take a while it would be a lot
better if we could just get a snapshot
of the actual game State itself so what
is the problem of doing this directly
from the game server well think about
this from an actual like incurrent
programming perspective now if I am a
client and I ask the game server for its
game State the game server now has to
basically pause and not add any
additional operations to the game State
while it's copying that object to return
back for me and that's a problem the
reason being that during that time every
single other client is still playing the
video game so maybe it takes a second to
copy that massive game State object and
send it back to me during that second
all of a sudden now the video game
pauses because the game uh the game
server can't basically process any more
updates it's grabbed a lock saying hey
I'm not going to allow you to touch the
game State and so that would be bad we
don't want to stop the game from
progressing so what can we do instead
well perhaps rather than having to grab
a lock right here to get the full State
and then this guy basically trying to do
an update and having their operation
blocked what we can do instead is
actually offload this entire
snapshotting Behavior to to another
server so how do I propose we do that is
this Overkill very possibly but I do
think that if you have a thousand people
trying to update State at the same time
it is absolutely not a trivial operation
to return a snapshot of it cool so let's
use a state machine replication tactic
to actually create this snapshot server
so as in typical Jordan fashion we're
going to throw a Kafka Q in here so
we've got our game server this guy is
taking in All State updates so for
example this could be like hey my
character it's going to put all of those
into Kafka which is nice because now
they're all ordered right they all have
an offset number and then we've got this
snapshot server that is consuming from
Kafka so the nice thing about the
snapshot server is that because all of
these updates are getting buffered in
Kafka there's not really much pressure
on the snapshot server to consume them
super fast if it has to pause for a
second that's okay then it can go back
to consuming all of the updates from
Kafka so the Snapchat server can go
ahead and do that and as it does
basically what ends up happening is that
the reader can uh do two things right so
let's say this guy went down and now he
wants to basically do a select And
subscribe where the select is saying
give me the snapshot and the Subscribe
is saying get me all new
messages what he could do is go over to
the game server and say hey I'm
listening to you again start sending me
all the new incremental messages and so
the game server starts sending it
messages so it sends him 22 right
message with offset 22 because all these
messages are ordered we can order them
because they're all going through one
place 22 23 and 24 and so now the reader
can say oh shoot you know what I need
everything up to message 21 before I can
apply these to my local state and so
what it's going to do is go to the
snapshot server say hey I would really
like a snapshot at state number 21 and
the snapshot server can go ahead and
give it to that right if it's possible
the snapshot Server doesn't actually
have all of those messages processed yet
maybe it's only me uh processed up to 19
for now we can use something like a long
poll to basically hang out over here and
then all of a sudden the snapshot server
will give it uh a snapshot if it's the
case that the snapshot server has
already processed let's say messages 22
and 23 that's totally fine too because
then we just won't process them on the
reader over here from the game server
and we'll only process message number 24
so basically we'll wait until we get a
snapshot with an offset greater than or
equal to the incoming messages offsets
and then from there we will you know
buffer all the incoming m messages in
memory and then apply their results
right after that now is it possible that
there are so many messages from the game
server in this very short period of time
that we completely take down the reader
I guess in theory yes like this is
always uh something that is going to be
plausible but at the same time I would
think that as long as the snapshot
server is reasonably fast this shouldn't
be too big of a concern cool so
hopefully that makes sense about how we
do this kind of Select And subscribe
functionality because we're actually
going to be using this in a few
different places throughout the video
which we'll get to in a little
bit okay next we're going to be talking
about building fault tolerance so of
course you know for their snapshot
server we've got Kafka for buffering
messages and you know it's fine if we
need to pause for a second because those
messages are going to be buffered in
Kafka however that does actually have a
couple of problems meaning that there is
more of a delay between when a message
uh gets published from our game server
and actually makes it to the snapshot
server and ideally if we want basically
a replica of our game server we want
that replica to be as up to-date as
possible additionally having Kofa as
another kind of middleman between the
game server and the snapshot server just
acts as another point of failure so what
can we actually do well this time we can
do like a full legit State machine
replication and talk about that a little
bit so in this case the game server as
opposed to basically publishing uh
messages through Kafka over to our
snapshot server it can actually publish
messages directly to the game server
replica this is what we call State
machine replication if you watch my
video on building a fast Stock Exchange
same concept that they use for building
their replicas out as well I'll make
that video again eventually but uh for
now you'll have to trust me so gist is
here that by using our state machine
replication we can imagine that
basically any message that gets sent
back to our users is also getting sent
to our game server
replica it is possible that this guy may
drop some messages uh but if it does
then you know it probably means that
other clients are going to be dropping
them too so uh you know we can have
multiple game server replicas if we
really needed to but the point is uh
they should hopefully keep it so that
most of our messages are not getting
lost and if this guy were to go down we
can use something like zookeeper to
promote this guy over here
cool okay now we're actually going to be
talking about networking a little bit
and perhaps even some front-end
optimizations to deal with with this so
like I mentioned uh especially when it
comes to certain uh interactions in the
game especially something like movement
I don't actually have to see all game
messages and it's useful for movement
right because movement is probably the
message that gets sent to the game
server the most right at all times all
players are moving they're not
necessarily shooting their gun uh but
they're certainly just moving around and
that's pretty important to understand
and so you know if I am talking about
movement in particular right if my
character is going here to here to here
and we drop the middle packet that's
okay because this is going to resolve
itself when I receive the character's
next location so unfortunately as I also
touched upon before this doesn't work
for All State messages right not all of
these things are kind of self-resolving
if I were to use an ability and that
didn't get sent out to every other
player all of a sudden it's as if I
didn't use that ability that would be
bad if I shot a bullet and it didn't see
to everyone else like I shot that bullet
that would be bad if the score didn't
get updated uh that would be bad so
there's certain messages that we don't
want to be dropping but there are others
that we can drop and so what you should
start thinking about here is actually a
particular uh types of networking
protocols such as TCP and UDP so for the
messages that we can't drop and for
those that we need to send in order
right like uh you know the score or my
kill death
ratio we should absolutely be using TCP
this is good also because it's going to
ensure that the messages get there in
order that we're not overloading uh
basically the network as we're sending
pets out and uh again it's going to be
useful for our state machine replication
at the same time there are going to be
certain messages that we okay with
dropping uh movement is the main one
that I thought of but I'm sure if you
really think about it there are probably
plenty of others that you can throw in
there and so for these we can actually
use UDP UDP is nice it's going to be a
little bit faster than TCP for a couple
of reasons the one being there's lower
overhead to the actual message headers
themselves uh you don't have to wait for
acknowledgements in order to ensure
ordering right you just go ahead and
send out m messages as you please which
is great and then also there's no
congestion control in TCP uh we do flow
control and congestion control and I
have a video devoted to this but the
gist is uh we don't really care if we're
overloading the network we're just going
to send out packets and hope we
don't cool so the fact that we're
dealing with UDP can actually make
things a bit tricky and uh even for TCP
as well if our server is particularly uh
slow it can make the game pretty choppy
on the user side right if you think
about actual modern gaming PCs these
days some of those monitors are able to
update at 240 frames per second and we
have good graphics cards that can
actually CH out that rate for lighter
games like csgo or valerant or something
like that and so the question is how do
we actually stop our uh clients from
having a pretty choppy experience
because they're not receiving updates
from the server as much right even if
you have a 10 ping which is great and
you're hearing from the server a 100
times a second your monitor is probably
updating more than that and so what a
tactic is that a lot of these games will
actually use is something called
interpolation so
interpolation is where we basically
assume that for certain things like
movement or maybe the movement of a
bullet that it is going to continue to
travel in its current path until we hear
otherwise from the server and you know
it's kind of game engines or physics
engines that do the this rendering but
the gist is you know if I'm already
moving in this direction and all of a
sudden I don't hear from the server my
computer is still going to assume that
I'm moving in this direction and it's
going to keep me moving that way if
you've ever played rocket league for
example and uh you're really lagging
what what you'll sometimes see is the
ball continues to move as if it's
dropping normally and then all of a
sudden your screen flashes back and you
realize that someone hit the ball and
it's moving in a completely different
direction that would be a perfect
example of interpolation it's just more
noticeable because you're experiencing
really bad lag cool so again this is
basically just predicting what the
movement's going to be sometimes it's
wrong the more server updates you get
the less noticeable this
is okay so we've now kind of discussed
the concept of having this centralized
game server where the game server is
pretty much responsible for ensuring uh
all of the State updates caching the
state and sending it out and receiving
it from users and if we're being honest
here we have to update this state very
often right like people are clicking
Keys constantly people are doing things
in these video games constantly and we
can easily overload the game server if
there are a thousand people on it so
what can we do instead well of course
like we mentioned leaderless replication
is kind of out of the question here or I
should say multi-leader replication
because we can't really afford right
conflicts however what we can do is
actually partition out our game servers
right so the question is how should we
partition it well you may be thinking oh
like let's take each user ID that's
playing in our video game and send it to
one random partition well that's not too
great because now all of a sudden let's
say I'm uh user one and I'm looking at
user two and user three in game and now
all of a sudden to know where their
location is in game I have to read a
different partition for user 2 and a
different partition partion for user 3
that's going to be too expensive it
would be a lot better if all of the
people whose State I cared about were on
my same partition and same goes for all
of the items so what we should be really
doing instead is partitioning by region
so if you imagine right over here that
this is actually the coordinate plane of
the game because all at the end of the
day all of these maps that you can play
on are just 2D
Maps what you can do is actually just
Shard them out by region of the
coordinate plan this actually is going
to look very similar to the Geo sharding
that we do with our indexes now to be
fair I doubt we're going to need like
tons of inner bounded boxes or anything
I bet probably sharding into four pieces
or nine pieces or something like that
would be more than enough but the gist
is you know if I'm this guy over here
and I only care about the items in this
circle right because that's all my
graphics card is capable of rendering
then it is pretty noticeable that I
actually only have to read from R2 and
same for this guy right here he only has
to read from R2 which is great because
all the things he cares about are on
that
server however this is going to get a
little bit more complicated when we have
a player who is at the border of these
region servers right so if I'm this guy
over here note that like kind of circle
of influence that I care about so how is
this actually going to work because now
all of a sudden I also care about All
State updates from this region uh which
are on region one and previously I was
only listening to the Region 2 server
now I'm close enough that I have to hear
back from region one so let's go ahead
and say say something like this you know
this guy is reaching out as it's moving
he's reaching out to the Region 2 server
uh to basically send it State updates
all of a sudden he's too close to region
one the region two server can say hey I
actually don't cover this area you've
got to go back to the load balancer to
figure out who does he hits the load
balancer in Step One the load balancer
says o you actually want to listen to
region one now as well so what do we do
well now we have to get all of the
existing state in region one how do we
do that we discussed this earlier not
only do we subscribe to region
one we also have to hit the region one
snapshot server and that's the only way
that we're able to get uh the existing
state otherwise we would get all new
State updates but we would have no idea
what the existing state is in this area
over here and that would be bad so again
we do our same normal like select And
subscribe process on the region one
server we then subscribe to all the
region One updates and now we're
actually simultaneously listening for
updates on tu servers at the same time
both region one and region
two where things start to get really
really dicey is actually when we do
cross partition rights so let's imagine
the following situation me as the
absolute American Sniper Chris tile type
that I am I'm standing over here in
region one and I'm about to snipe Tech
lead standing over here in region two at
the same time he happens to be close
enough to the boundary between Region 2
and region one one but on the region two
side and he also shoots me so the
problem is if we both shoot at the same
time my right goes to region one his
right goes to region two eventually
because we're listening to the state
from both of these uh we're going to see
that we were shot both of us but we're
not actually going to know who wins
because I'm also going to see that I
shot him so that's a problem right when
we have two rights like this that could
possibly conflict with one another
across two different partitions we
basically need some method of actually
performing order ing on them and as we
know the only way to do this type of
thing is to use something like a
distributed lock so fortunately we have
devoted an entire video on how to build
distributed locking and so you do know
that the right way to do this is via
zookeeper so that's the way that I will
discuss it in this video that being said
um if you don't really care about having
perfect fault tolerance uh which may be
the case here maybe you'd be better off
using redus as a distributed lock
because that way you're reading and
writing right to memory and so yeah sure
your distributed lock not perfect but uh
it's probably going to save you a lot of
latency not having to do a bunch of two
commits uh two-phase commits with an
zookeeper and uh yeah I would think this
would be considerably faster so do keep
that in mind but I am ultimately going
to show zookeeper in the final diagram
so yeah what's the idea here well you
know it's even possible that we could
have a third guy over here on Region 3
and he's also shooting at the both of us
because you know maybe we can all see
one another we're all at the border of
our three region servers regardless
we're all going to have to try and grab
this lock for our particular region
servers and once we do it is basically
going to ensure that all of our rights
are ordered one of them wins and the
other people you know subsequently hear
about that right and their right is not
allowed to
proceed cool let us now talk about the
last aspect of this video which is going
to be dynamic partitioning
so as you can see I've got like seven
steps on this diagram and uh that's
going to be a lot for me to go through
but we're going to try and do it as I
begin to lose my voice here so basically
the question is uh our game is
progressing right um and our Zone that
everyone can occupy gets smaller so it's
possible that that zone can actually be
located in a single region server and if
not enough people have died yet now all
of a sudden maybe out of our thousand
people 100 have died but everyone now
again is located in a single region
server and that would be bad uh our
region server can become overloaded so
how would we deal with something like
this
well in the last uh in the last two
slides I introduced this load balancer
over here so ideally what we're going to
have is a pretty uh smart load balancer
that is doing the following we've got
some smart sort of load balancer which
I'll call the master server which is
basically listening from Zoo uh to
zookeeper and zookeeper is getting
constant heartbeats from all of our
region servers saying how much load
they're under right maybe their CPU
usage their memory usage something like
that and when it crosses a certain
threshold we can put that that in
Zookeeper and the master server can
actually read from it you can just put a
watch in Zookeeper and that way the
master server will hear when that entry
is updated cool so Master server hears
about it what does it do in step two it
actually goes back to zookeeper and says
hey I also happen to note that there's
an idle server over here I would like to
go ahead and uh convert this thing to
basically split the region one server in
half to a region 1A server and then the
idle server will become the region 1B
server so the master server is then
going to basically change the zoo uh the
Zookeeper configuration so it does that
successfully now all of a sudden the
idle server understands that it is the
region 1B server but here's the problem
is it has no state right this was just
completely idle it wasn't doing anything
we just have a few extra computers
laying around specifically for this
purpose in the event that servers get
overloaded so what does it do now well
it says oh shoot I've just become the
region 1B server what is the region 1 a
server that I'm getting this from and
once it hears from zookeeper and figures
that all out what are we going to do
again we're going to use our existing
snapshot And subscribe functionality so
that's reading from both the region one
server as well as the region one
snapshot
server and it is basically duplicating
the exact state that the region one
server had on it because now all of a
sudden uh we have all of the region 1B
State on there because it's only half of
what was on region one so now all of a
sudden we are perfectly up to date and
we're still still subscribed to this
region one server getting all of its
updates okay once that subscription is
complete right once we're caught up we
can go ahead and tell the region one
server that and all the region one
server has to do is continue sending all
of its messages over to this guy and
then just like that kick all of the
clients that are actively connected to
it that should now be on region 1B
simple enough what's GNA happen now is
basically this guy over here who was
just kicked is going to reach back out
to the master server which effectively
acts like a load balancer the master
server is going to say hey why don't you
connect to the region 1B server now and
then all of a sudden this guy is going
to start subscribing to the region 1B
server uh at which point he is good to
go it could be a select And subscribe as
well just in the event that there were
multiple clients and multiple clients
have been sending events to this guy in
the meantime uh but hopefully you get
the point here of how we might be going
about doing something like this it's
definitely not something easy to do uh
but it may actually be warranted if it's
possible that one of these servers can
get enough load on
it okay cool now just to quickly lay out
all of our pieces that we've been uh
discussing throughout this video
basically we've got our client over here
on the
left the client is always going to be
connecting via the master server to any
of these region servers and the reason
it's doing that is because the master
server is aware via zookeeper over here
of which uh server is which particular
region and which one it should
correspond to to and as a result of that
the first thing that we want to do
whenever we're connecting to a region
server is establish something like a
websocket connection with it the reason
being that uh even though we are going
to be sending a lot of UDP updates at
the end of the day we have to send a lot
of TCP ones as well and it would be
great if we could establish a persistent
connection that doesn't require us
sending headers over and over and over
again so websocket at least to me seems
pretty ideal here so we're using our
websocket to basically say things like
hey I shot a bullet hey my kill went up
something like that and so the region
one server is now all of a sudden
communicating directly with our client
via websocket and additionally via UDP
for those droppable updates because
ideally that is going to uh be faster
cool at the same time uh the region one
server is doing a couple things it is
using State machine replication over
here to send messages to the region one
backup server it's also sending messages
via Kafka to the region one snapshot
server and in addition although I didn't
really draw it out here we might have an
additional server that can be used for
anti-che cool hopefully that makes sense
Region 2 server will be doing exactly
the same thing we've got a backup we've
got a snapshot server additionally we've
got some passive Master server because
at the end of the day whenever we have
one master server like this it can
always go down this is pretty easy to
keep up the passive Mass uh Master
server can just be doing the same exact
thing also listening to
zookeeper having the same exact State
and if this guy were to ever be hard
beating to zookeeper and then stops
doing so the passive Master server can
take over clients can read zookeeper to
realize that that's where the new Master
server lives the last piece of this
puzzle is actually going to be the
distributed lock which like I mentioned
I want to live in Zookeeper stop an
ambulance this is not cool like I
mentioned I want this to live in
Zookeeper just is client has to go ahead
and grab the distributed lock when doing
multi-partition writes but other than
that if they're just writing to a single
partition at a time
they can go ahead and uh avoid that
distributed lock we just need to have
all those rights that are across
multiple partitions uh be linearizable
and blocking one another so we don't
have right conflicts okay guys actually
not as long as I thought this would be
which is great because I am very tired
so I hope you enjoy the video and I will
see you in the next one